For the first time to sign a roll board
switch after 6 or 8 months of hard work and see it properly,
is the best feeling in the world.
2 years ago I and a friend were the first Argentines
who won an international robotics competition.
I felt I had to tell people and help more and more people
to involve in robotics.
I started traveling through the country and teaching robotics
so that the kids can get fantastic tools for the future.
I see how they work with a robot, and they feel like they're just playing,
but they learn how to become incredibly competent.
They think, "I'm too young to do this kind of thing,"
but they are not. So when you get this idea
planting them, they become unstoppable.
However, one of my goals is to create a generation of good robot developers,
and good competitors that will change the world.
Mateo is also the founder of ¡Hablalo !,
a program to help deaf and dumb people communicate more easily.
Mateo Salvatto.
Robotikakampioen.
Program maker.
We celebrate programmers worldwide
Share your # IMakeApps story